okay so the ccsd kids are in spring
break right now but sherry it's not too
early to start thinking about summer
summer camps are already starting to
open up and open registration bianca
holmen is live to share how you can
figure out which camp is right for you
your family and maybe your budget right
bianca
you're exactly right sherry good morning
nate good morning shared morning
everybody so yeah sign up is open now
for cams across the valley especially
for camps like the one here at the ymca
they have their registration open now so
from may 31st to august 5th camp
silverscreen is coming to the ymca it's
time to start planning for summer so
going to summer camp is a great time for
children to build their self-esteem make
new friends and try new activities it's
also a great time for kids to take a
break from those screens we spoke with
kimberly mcgee from vegas kid zone she
has a blog about getting kids back into
the swing of things
when you're looking for a camp
really go into what your child needs
because if your child's going to be
happy there um then a lot of other
things are going to fall into place
when you go um
just instead of just looking online go
talk to the to the directors if you can
talk to the people
be working directly with your child ask
them what happens um if my child's
uncomfortable that day and what are in
place to call me and and get that
solved or what do you have in place to
get them comfortable there at on
premises
mcgee also says really understand the
camp's policy around mass and cova 19
protocols and of course their refund
policy for example if your child is out
sick for a week can you get at least
some of your money back and coming up in
the next half hour we have some more
tips on choosing the best camp for your
family reporting live bianca holman live
local now